okay Rob this is John again maybe I have  a sympathetic understanding situation  but when we see for peer stayed it in  stock apparent if you have a wouldn't  surprise me if you've gone on to make a  deal and work with the governor I  understand that you can't change  joint upon such Linton if on the other  hand well this information that  implicates the president then we've got  a national security issue or maybe you  can add some security issue I don't know  some issue you've got to forget to deal  with all for the cousin of the country  so you know then when you only need some  kind of heads-up just for the sake of  protecting all all in cases we can  without you having to give up any  competent information so and if it's the  former then remember what we've always  said about the president is you employed  fling now that's still reliable  anyway um let me know and I appreciate  your listening and taking the time  thanks Paul